Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
J’ai une question pour vous
et j’aimerais que vous puissiez y répondre
avec toute la rigueur de votre savoir.
Sept plus quatre ?
Onze.
Plus trois ?
Quatorze.
Moins cinq ?
Neuf.
Attention, roulements de tambour.
Racine carrée de neuf ?
(Public) Trois.
Trois.
Vous êtes brillants. Et je ne me
moque pas, vous êtes brillants.
Sachez que ces opérations-là n’ont été
possibles pour le commun des mortels
qu’à partir du 8e siècle
après Jésus-Christ.
Il a fallu la clairvoyance d'un calife.
Le calife Al-Mamun à Bagdad.
Il a convoqué son meilleur mathématicien
et lui a dit :
« J’aimerais que tu nous écrives
un petit opuscule,
grâce à quoi chacun pourra résoudre
les soucis de son quotidien. »
Ce que l'on appelle, lorsqu'on est petit,
faire des problèmes.
Combien faut-il
dans le porte-monnaie d’une ménagère
pour qu’elle puisse au marché acheter
trois citrouilles à trois euros ?
Si vous êtes devenu ainsi
magnifiquement forts en calcul mental,
c’est grâce à des professeurs des écoles
qui vous ont entraînés pendant des années.
Vous avez eu ensuite des professeurs
qui vous ont mis en place
toutes les règles de l'arithmétique.
J’ai une deuxième question :
Qui vient ici et en 90 secondes,
me donne envie de travailler avec elle
ou de travailler avec lui ?
Et là, il n’y a plus personne.
(Rires)
Pourquoi ?
Mais vous souvenez-vous du nom de
votre dernier professeur d’art oratoire ?
Ils ont tous disparu en 1895 en France.
Dans cette dernière décennie
du 19e siècle, en réalité,
tous les cours de rhétorique
ont disparu partout,
Grande-Bretagne, Allemagne,
Italie, France, États-Unis.
Or, cette fin de siècle, voyez-vous,
était très mécanisée.
On avait besoin d’ingénieurs,
on avait besoin de techniciens.
On était également en train de rénover
toute la pédagogie de l’enseignement.
C'était le siècle de Jules Ferry.
Voilà pourquoi, depuis 120 ans,
vous êtes orphelins de la parole.
Depuis 120 ans, vous êtes
des autodidactes de la parole.
Vous n'avez plus aucun référentiel.
Il y a certainement
des exceptions magnifiques.
Par exemple, ces professeurs
de français courageux
qui continuent à donner
un, deux, trois, quatre cours
d'art oratoire à leurs élèves.
Vous avez également l’oral du bac,
mais je m’interroge :
pourquoi les lycéens sont-ils devenus
mes nouveaux clients ?
Et enfin, vous avez
les exceptions glorieuses :
HEC, Sciences Po,
Centrale Supélec, Polytechnique.
Admettez avec moi qu’il s’agit là
d’une toute petite population d’élite,
mais ce n’est pas le commun des mortels.
Je vous propose pendant quelques minutes
de pousser la porte à double
battant de la rhétorique.
Nous voici au 6e siècle
avant Jésus-Christ.
Nous sommes en Sicile,
Agrigente et Syracuse.
Ces deux villes sont
sous le joug d’un dictateur.
Voici qu'il chute.
Et la population revient.
S’ensuivent des procès en cascades
car tous veulent récupérer
leur lopin de terre, leur maison.
Alors deux avocats, Corax et Tisias,
commencent à écrire
le premier traité d’argumentaire.
Ce traité voyage, arrive à Athènes.
Là, les grands noms que vous connaissez
s’en saisissent et le complètent.
Nous avons donc Socrate,
puis nous avons Aristote,
nous avons Platon.
Au quatrième siècle avant Jésus-Christ,
tout est écrit.
La caisse à outils de la rhétorique
est complète.
Plus personne n’ajoutera
un seul outil dans la caisse.
Vingt-cinq siècles.
Alors, qu’est-ce qui change ?
Tout d’abord, voyez-vous, cela fait dire
que la rhétorique a une origine
et elle n'a pas d'histoire.
En revanche, ce qui va changer,
c’est la façon dont on va utiliser
cette boîte à outils.
Cela s'appelle l'éloquence.
Et là, je peux vous assurer
que vos grands orateurs sont un peu
comme vos grands peintres,
comme vos grands sculpteurs,
ils travaillent la mélodie du beau,
la mélodie du verbe.
Ils vont travailler les cadences,
ils vont travailler les tempos.
« S’ils avaient disserté sur des idées
nouvelles, j’aurais gardé le silence. »
Démosthène.
« Jusqu’ à quand abuseras-tu
de notre patience, Catilina ? »
Cicéron.
« Madame se meurt, Madame est morte. »
Bossuet.
« Nous nous battrons sur les plages,
nous nous battrons dans les rues.
Jamais nous ne nous rendrons. »
Churchill.
« Je sais que mon histoire
n’est possible dans aucun autre pays
que les États-Unis. »
Obama.
« Ich bin ein Berliner. »
Kennedy.
« J’ai fait un rêve. »
Martin Luther King.
Vous connaissez toutes
ces phrases et d’autres encore.
Vous voyez que tous ces grands orateurs
ont marqué votre cœur,
ont marqué votre mémoire,
ont marqué votre esprit.
Ils travaillent la mélodie des mots.
Aujourd’hui, on ne parle plus
comme parlait François Mitterrand.
On ne parle plus aujourd’hui
comme parlait Jacques Chirac.
François Mitterrand disait
de Jacques Chirac
qu’il s’exprimait
comme on tape à la machine.
(Rires)
Il ajoutait : « Il monte avec ses idées,
il redescend avec les miennes. »
(Rires)
L’éloquence varie selon les époques,
elle varie aussi selon les personnes.
Quelle est votre éloquence ?
Voyez-vous, parler, c’est entrer
en relation avec l’autre par la parole.
C’est un joli mot que « relation ».
Il vient du latin « relatio »,
qui signifie - première acception -
petit rapport administratif
délivré au Sénat.
Deuxième acception :
c’est une histoire.
Entrer en relation avec l’autre
par la parole,
c’est commencer une histoire avec l’autre.
Avouez que c'est de toute beauté humaine.
Et c’est valable autant dans le domaine
professionnel que dans le domaine privé.
En politique, vous ne pouvez pas avoir
de politique sans programme politique,
de programme sans discours politique,
de discours sans débat politique.
La parole est intrinsèquement liée
à l’histoire de la Cité.
Dans le management, c’est pareil,
vous ne pouvez pas avoir de management
sans l’exercice de la parole,
sans qu’à un moment donné,
le chef d’entreprise prenne la parole,
au minimum pour expliquer
son projet entrepreneurial.
Et ensuite, il passera sur la motivation,
c’est-à-dire pouvoir,
rien que par la grâce des mots,
allumer chez chacune
de ses collaboratrices,
chacun de ses collaborateurs,
une flamme par laquelle la conviction
du projet deviendra une action.
Ils porteront, elles porteront
alors le projet entrepreneurial
et le réaliseront.
Et ensuite, il fédérera,
et c’est encore plus sublime.
Il fera naître dans le cœur, dans l’esprit
de chacun, de chacune,
cette idée magnifique
qu’il existe une entité abstraite,
bien supérieure à ce que chacun se trouve
être et à laquelle on aime appartenir,
et qui s'appelle l'entreprise.
Et puis, il y a l'amour.
Il ne peut pas y avoir d'amour
sans déclaration d'amour.
Parlons de la vôtre.
La veille encore, vous étiez tout nerveux.
Vous tournicotiez dans votre chambre,
dans votre salon.
Vous ne saviez pas comment vous y prendre.
Finalement, vous avez passé
une nuit intranquille.
Au lendemain au petit jour, encore remué
par les bouleversements de la veille,
vous vous êtes finalement présenté tout
pantelant, tout chancelant, tout hésitant,
et elle est tombée dans vos bras.
Avez-vous relu Flaubert ? Non.
Chateaubriand, non, Victor Hugo, non.
Avez-vous réussi un chiasme magnifique ?
Non.
Une anadiplose sublime ? Non plus.
Elle vous l’a dit, d’ailleurs,
quelques semaines plus tard :
« Tu sais, tu étais particulièrement
maladroit ce jour-là,
particulièrement gauche.
Mais qu’est-ce que tu étais sincère ! »
Et, voyez-vous, ça,
cette sincérité,
c’est-à-dire cet art sublime
de pouvoir s’exprimer
avec un alignement parfait
entre ce que vous pensez,
ce que vous dites
et ce que vous vivez
au moment où vous le dites,
cette sincérité-là, c’est le premier
principe de l’éloquence.
Parlez comme vous êtes, vous ne pourrez
jamais parler comme Churchill.
En revanche, vous parlerez
toujours comme vous êtes.
Vous parlez avec vos bibliothèques,
vous parlez avec vos livres,
vous parlez avec vos sensations,
vos émotions, votre intelligence.
Vous parlez avec votre corps,
vous parlez avec votre esprit, votre cœur.
C'est charnel, la parole.
Arrêtez de penser un seul instant
que c’est intellectuel,
c'est d'abord là que ça se passe.
« Oui, mais je suis timide »,
« N’est pas venu
celui qui va me faire parler en public. »
« Autant construire
des châteaux en Espagne. »
Deux réflexions :
faut-il vraiment être en Espagne
pour construire des châteaux ?
(Rires)
Plus précisément,
je prends votre timidité.
Vos parents ont tenté de vous changer
en vingt ans et n’y sont pas parvenus.
Alors prenons un autre chemin :
considérons votre singularité.
Peut-être cette timidité est-elle
vécue par vous comme un fardeau.
Alors allons plus avant
dans votre personnalité
et glanons encore
quelques grains de courage
par lesquels nous allons
enceindre cette timidité
et tout en gardant ce que vous êtes,
votre réserve, votre façon d’être,
vous allez commencer à parler
précisément comme vous êtes
et c’est pour cela
qu’on viendra vous écouter.
C’est pour cela
qu’on viendra vous entendre
et c’est pour cela que vous commencerez
à être persuasif.
Ne vous disloquez jamais,
parlez comme vous êtes.
Il y a peut-être une éloquence
mystérieuse dans tout cela.
C’est celle des starlettes
de la télé-réalité.
(Rires)
Elles nous ont quand même affublés d’un
bon nombre d’aphorismes impressionnants.
« L’âge ne fait pas le moine. »
(Rires)
« Les philosophes pensent encore. »
« Je suis têtue comme une moule. »
(Rires)
Là, c’est les conchyliculteurs, perplexes.
Vous parlez comme vous êtes.
Ayez bien confiance dans ce que vous êtes.
Y aurait-il, au-delà de cela,
une autre règle,
un autre principe d’éloquence ?
Assurément.
Quand je vous le dirai,
vous le verrez et vous me croirez.
Il n’appartient pas à notre 21e siècle :
quand nous n’avons rien à dire,
taisons-nous.
Je vous assure que
ce n’est pas notre siècle.
La démocratie nous a donné l’exercice,
la liberté de la parole.
Si nous étions des gens
de goût et élégants,
nous tempérerions l’exercice de la parole.
Précisément par le fait de se taire
chaque fois que nous n’avons rien à dire.
Et nous sommes tant à n'avoir rien à dire.
« De toutes celles et ceux qui n’ont rien
à dire, celles et ceux qui nous plaisent,
ce sont ceux qui se taisent. »
Coluche.
« La démocratie a donné la parole
à des milliers d’imbéciles.
Les réseaux sociaux ont donné la parole
à des milliers d’imbéciles
qui, avant, se trouvaient simplement
au bar, dans un troquet,
devant un verre de vin,
déversaient leurs sottises,
rentraient chez eux,
ne faisaient de mal à personne.
Depuis, ils ont le même droit
à la parole qu’un prix Nobel.
C’est la démocratie des imbéciles. »
Ces mots sont de votre Garde des Sceaux,
Eric Dupond-Moretti.
Et peut-être, voyez-vous, sur ce thème,
la plus belle conclusion appartient
à un sénateur, le sénateur Malhuret,
lorsqu’il nous dit :
« Finalement, en 2500 ans,
on est passé de Socrate sur l’Agora
à Francis Lalanne sur Facebook. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Considérant ce premier principe, je vous
propose de le résumer en une phrase :
mieux vaut fermer sa gueule
et risquer de passer pour un con
plutôt que de l’ouvrir
et d’ôter tout doute là-dessus.
(Rires et applaudissements)
Y aurait-il un autre principe ?
Assurément.
Le troisième principe
de l’éloquence est très beau.
Il est très délicat.
Si vous dites quelque chose,
c’est que cela ne va pas de soi,
c’est que vous avez considéré
qu’il valait mieux
casser ce silence qui nous unissait
pour pouvoir disloquer des malentendus.
Chaque fois que vous dites quelque chose,
c'est que le silence ne suffit plus.
Il était d’or,
vous y ajoutez une parole d’argent,
précisément pour pouvoir
construire autre chose
que le malentendu contenu dans le silence.
Un ami me disait il y a trois
semaines à peu près :
« Je vais ouvrir un magasin.
J’ai déjà acheté une cagoule et un pied
de biche » - ça ne va pas de soi.
(Rires)
Les partis politiques dissertent
encore aujourd’hui
pour savoir s’il faut réduire le nombre
de fonctionnaires dans l’administration.
C’est que cela ne va pas de soi.
Ce qui permet, voyez-vous, encore
aujourd’hui, à l’administration française
de considérer qu’elle est peut-être la
chose la plus proche de la vie éternelle.
Il y a un dernier principe,
tout dernier principe d’éloquence,
c’est que, dès lors que vous dites quelque
chose, vous mettez cette chose en débat.
Vous permettez à chacun
de penser autrement.
Vous permettez à chacun,
éventuellement, de vous contredire,
de vous dire son avis, son opinion.
Dès que vous mettez quelque chose
sur la place publique,
la chose ne vous appartient plus.
Le débat démarre.
En 2016, nous sommes
au 300 000e mensonge de Trump
comptabilisé par le Washington Post
et le New York Times.
Le 26 décembre de cette année-là,
il tweete ceci :
« Avant ma victoire, le moral
des Américains était au plus bas.
Depuis que j’ai gagné,
la croissance est de 10 %
et les dépenses de Noël des Américains
avoisinent les 1 000 milliards
de dollars. »
À peine a-t-il tweeté
que c’est sur la place publique.
On peut commencer à vérifier,
puis ensuite à contredire,
puis ensuite à infirmer ou à confirmer,
à médire, si vous le souhaitez,
en tous les cas, à débattre.
Regardez, quatre principes.
Le premier :
« Soyez vous-même, soyez sincère. »
Le deuxième : « Si nous n’avons
rien à dire, taisons-nous. »
Le troisième : « Si vous dites quelque
chose, c’est que cela ne va pas de soi. »
Le dernier :
« Si vous dites quelque chose,
c’est que vous mettez la chose en débat. »
Il y a une seule exception à ce principe.
C’est lorsque, voyez-vous, votre amie,
votre ami, votre épouse,
dans cette belle après-midi d’automne
où vous avez encore un soleil
rasant sur l’horizon,
dans le silence du salon, vous dit :
« Je peux te poser une question ? »
Messieurs, sachez qu’à ce moment-là,
l’enquête est close et le procès commence.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J'ai une toute dernière
question pour vous.
Avec tout cela, voyez-vous,
aurez-vous le courage,
aurez-vous le courage d’être vous-même,
d’aller chercher les mots
qui vous ressemblent ?
Aurez-vous le courage d’aller voir
à l’intérieur de vous
ces particularités qui sont les vôtres,
c’est-à-dire vos défauts,
mais autant vos qualités,
pour pouvoir nous dire
quelque chose qui est à vous,
quelque chose qui vous ressemble,
et non qui ressemble à monsieur
et madame Tout-le-monde, à la foule ?
Non, surtout pas !
Aurez-vous ce courage-là ?
Il ne faut pas de courage
pour être comme tout le monde.
Dans ce cas-là, habillez-vous comme eux,
pensez comme eux, marchez comme eux,
vous aurez les mêmes émotions, les mêmes
sensations, vous aurez les mêmes idées.
Il ne faut pas de courage pour cela.
Aurez-vous le courage, tout simplement,
de vous dire que vous aussi,
avec tout ce que vous êtes,
vous pouvez avoir cette facilité
de transmettre une idée
par la puissance des mots ?
Ne me dites pas
que vous avez fait tout ce chemin,
que vous avez vécu toute cette vie,
pour aujourd’hui vous confondre
dans l’anonymat d’une foule.
Aurez-vous ce courage ?
Je le crois.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)